for the first time ever Silicon Valley
hosted its very own comic-con in other
words the nerdiest conference came to
the nerdiest town in the u.s. the first
installment of a new Bay Area convention
couldn't exactly measure up to the San
Diego incarnation that dominates
entertainment headlines every year in
July but it didn't disappoint in terms
of crazy fanfare with a tech oriented
twist convention goers could ride a
hoverboard at a booth with a fan built
DeLorean time machine yes these two
converted a DeLorean into a Back to the
Future time machine as Huey Lewis would
say that's the power of love when we saw
the car come out of Doc's van we thought
would that be the greatest kind of car
to drive when I'd be funny Alan Tudyk
and Nathan Fillion of Firefly in the new
web series conman charmed the pants off
nearly everyone during their panel and
legendary marvel comics creators Stan
Lee held court over the most popular
panels on Sunday over the course of
three days nearly 60,000 people visited
the convention and true to Silicon
Valley's reputation for iterative
improvement woz says version 2.0 in 2017
will be even better